hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today I want to talk to you
about the life cycle of the parasite
that causes the disease schistosomiasis
nauseousness myiasis if you give these
caused by a flatworm ailment parasite so
parasite meaning that it is a type of a
type of symbiotic relationship so we
know that parasitism is a form of
symbiosis symbiosis being where two
organisms live in very close contact so
it's a parasite specifically is a
flatworm helmet that's the type of worm
but it is and it is sex between 200 and
300 million people annually so that's a
significant burden to this local
population it is caused by several
different species of shifts of Soma so
sister soma is the genus name and there
are several species within this genus
and they all cause schistosomiasis with
some sort of slight differences between
them now like hookworm which is another
parasite that I had a video about if
you're interested in learning about the
hookworm parasite life cycle please
refer to that video the white hookworm
this justice OMA parasite also burrows
directly through unbroken skin of the
host in other words it does not need a
cut in the skin through which to enter
it converts your healthy unbroken skin
and specifically if it's doing this to
people who are exposed to infected water
so for example you have people that are
working on say the rice harvest so
they're needy in water and the rice
paddies that's that's a very common mode
of transmission for
a parasite now interestingly this
parasite is life cycle also involved
with there is an intermediate host this
means that while humans are the
definitive host where the sexual
reproduction of the parasite happens the
parasite life cycle also requires an
intermediate host where a form of
asexual reproduction is happening and
we'll talk about that here in a little
bit but the intermediate host in
particular is a type of water snail
now I already told you a little bit
about symbiosis and how it is this
really close relationship between two
living organisms who live in close
contact parasitism is what is known as a
plus minus form that is because one
species in the interaction benefits and
one species is harmed here the species
that benefits of course is this
schistosomiasis that is harmed is of
course the human host if you are
interested in learning more about
symbiosis and about other types of
symbiosis including mutualism and
commensalism please see my video on the
different types of symbiosis now let's
talk about that what the life cycle of
Bash is the soma one assort right here
so the way that eggs are introduced into
infected water is through either human
urine or feces and whether it's urine or
feces is going to depend on which feces
is just the soma you're talking about
so eggs shed in human urine or feces the
eggs don't hatch they release a new
developmental stage is called Maris
idiom or on your video the nearest Cydia
invade the snail so invade the snail
tissue where they mature into a new
developmental form called a spore assess
the spores that then reproduce asexually
and as they're reproducing asexually
they're releasing another developmental
stage call sir carry a look like this
into the water now sir carrying a are
movable that means they can swim
so the sir carrier in the water they
will develop into another form called
schistosomiasis particular lifecycle is
with all of these different
developmental stages now the shift of
Sanyal a can then penetrate
excuse me mister carry a penetrate
unbroken skin and one inside became a
host backer they develop into these just
a Sanyal a it's just so Sanyal a then
travel through the hosts bloodstream to
the liver and it is the liver where this
is so samuel a mature into adult worms
these worms are interesting here we have
a male and a female and the way that
they exist together is the male worm
actually hold the female learn in a
groove in his body so once this is the
song Lavery to deliver and mature into
adult these adults then travel to
different parts of the eye to the
gastrointestinal tract or the urinary
tract again it depends on which species
of shift the stoma you are looking at
which of these areas are going to go to
so the GI tract is your airing tract if
at that point they have this association
and a female is held within a group in
the male body and they release pain and
these worms can live inside a home for
upwards of 10 years just releasing eggs
all the time and then of course those
eggs then get shed into human urine get
shed with human urine or feces for to be
human exit or a system and then the
process will continue
now we typically don't hear about
schistosomiasis in the United States it
is mainly a tropical disease there is
also a disease that is a much bigger
concern among developing nation and that
is because countries like the United
States that have proper public health
infrastructure and proper sanitation
don't have these types of don't have
human urine and feces getting into
contact with water that people are
generally spending time in and so that
helps to break that chain of
transmission also it is through
penetrating unbroken skin that's how the
cercariae are getting into the human
host and so if a person does not have
their bare skin and contact with
infected water than that also sort of
breaks that transmission and then also
we do have anti helmet that can sure
someone of a schistosomiasis inspection
if it is diagnosed and so that brings us
to the end of this video if you are
interested in learning about the life
cycle of the hookworm parasite please
see my video on that topic and thanks
for watching biology professor